From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Nancy Updike, and I'm filling in for Ira Glass, who's working on a great, action-heavy, live stage show. He will be back next week.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是南希·厄普代克，我正在为艾拉·格拉斯代班，他目前正在筹备一场精彩、充满动作元素的现场演出。他下周就会回来。
And in the meantime, I wanted to share this story. It's a little personal. I was at MAC-- the makeup store, not the computer store-- and I was buying foundation, which I almost never wear. That's the makeup you put all over your face to give yourself pretend perfect skin.
在此期间，我想分享这个故事。它有点私人。我当时在 MAC——是化妆品店，不是电脑店——我在买粉底，我几乎从不用它。那是你涂在整张脸上，让自己看起来皮肤完美无瑕的化妆品。
And I asked the salesman for help finding the right color. And he looked at me and said-- almost like he was thinking out loud-- he said, your neck, it's so much more yellow than your face. And then he turned away to start looking for the impossible color that would solve this problem of the yellow right next to the so much more yellow.
我请售货员帮忙找合适的颜色。他看着我说——就像在自言自语一样——他说，你的脖子比你的脸黄太多了。然后他转过身去，开始寻找那种不可能存在的颜色，来解决这个紧挨着明显更黄的肤色的黄度问题。
And if you're thinking, oh, this was just a sales technique to invent a problem and then offer to fix it with more products, I wish that that had been the case. But this was not an upsell. This was a cri de couer. The man really just seemed to be expressing his frustration at this stumper of my mismatched face and neck.
如果你认为，哦，这只是发明一个问题然后推销更多产品来解决它的销售技巧，我倒希望是这样。但这并不是为了促销，而是一种发自内心的感慨。那个人似乎真的在为我这不协调的脸和脖子带来的难题感到沮丧。
This sort of out-of-the-blue, perfectly sharpened comment stops you cold because it's not an insult. It's an observation that is true. You just hadn't thought of it before. It's shocking because you think, I know myself. I know what I've got, what I haven't got. No one's going to spot something about me that I haven't already seen. Not true. You can be among friends, doing something you love, feeling great--
这种突如其来的、精准犀利的评论会让你瞬间僵住，因为它不是侮辱，而是一种事实观察。你只是之前没想过而已。这很令人震惊，因为你会想，我了解我自己。我知道我有什么，没什么。没人能发现我还没注意到的关于我自己的东西。事实并非如此。你可以和朋友在一起，做着你喜欢的事，感觉棒极了——
We were backstage, you know, getting ready to go on, preparing.
我们当时在后台，你知道，准备登台，正在候场。
This is Dee Watson. She was in a play a few weeks ago.
这是迪·沃森。她几周前演了一部戏。
And it was all black women. Most of us were a little bit bigger than the average, you know. And it was a supportive atmosphere. And the subject of big behinds came up. And me having one, I know all about it. And one of the younger cast members-- she was about 25-- said, my mother thought your butt was so big it had to be a prop.
全都是黑人女性。我们大多数人都比一般人胖一点，你知道的。那是种很支持彼此的氛围。然后话题转到了大屁股上。作为一个有大屁股的人，我对此很了解。其中一个年轻的演员——她大约 25 岁——说，我妈妈以为你的屁股太大，一定是塞了道具。
Oh my god.
天哪。
And at that moment, I didn't hear anything else anybody said. I just was-- that was echoing through my head, and I could hear everybody laughing. And oh my gosh, that's so funny. And I'm standing there. I wanted to cry. I really wanted to cry. And I really don't think this young girl really meant to hurt me.
那一刻，我没听见别人说的任何话。我只是——那句话在我的脑海里回响，我能听到每个人都在笑。天哪，那太好笑了。我站在那里。我想哭。我真的想哭。而且我真的不认为这个年轻女孩是故意想伤害我。
Well, and maybe it's like, you know, we're all women, so it's safe here to say anything.
嗯，可能就像是，你知道，我们都是女人，所以在这里说什么都安全。
Yeah. I think she thought I would think that was funny, and I did not.
是啊。我觉得她以为我会觉得那很好笑，但我并没有。
These are not statements that a human being forgets. The moment you hear the observation, it becomes part of how you see yourself, seemingly forever. Even something tiny, if it hits you right, can turn into this chirpy little voicemail that your brain is never able to erase.
这些都是人类无法忘记的话。一旦你听到这种观察，它就成了你看待自己方式的一部分，似乎永远如此。即使是一些微小的事情，如果它触动了你，它就会变成那种你的大脑永远无法抹去的喋喋不休的语音留言。
And it doesn't have to be about looks. It can be a comment on how you run or laugh or drive, how much money you make, what books you've read or haven't read-- any outside assessment of you that you never saw coming and could not shake once it was uttered.
而且这不一定非得是关于外貌。它可以是对你跑步、大笑或开车方式的评价，你挣多少钱，你看过或没看过什么书——任何你意想不到且一旦说出口就无法摆脱的外部评价。
One of our former producers, Jane Feltes-- she's actually now Jane Marie-- years ago dated a man who she later decided was a jerk. He wanted to make her feel insecure. But one night they were watching TV, and her feet were sticking up out of the blanket.
我们的一位前制作人简·费尔特斯——她现在叫简·玛丽——多年前和一个后来被她认为是混蛋的男人约会。他想让她感到自卑。但有一天晚上，他们正在看电视，她的脚从毯子里伸了出来。
And he turned to me, and he said, oh, you have juice box toes. And I was like, what? And he said, yeah, like Fred Flintstone feet. He's a caveman-- literally a caveman. A cartoon of a caveman-- a chubby, squat cartoon of a caveman.
他转向我，说，哦，你有果汁盒脚趾。我说，什么？他说，是啊，就像弗莱德·弗林石的脚。他是穴居人——真的是个穴居人。一个穴居人的卡通画——一个肥胖、矮蹲的卡通穴居人。
And I know it sounds so stupid, because who cares what shape my toes are? But you do want the person that you're in love with to just think that every part of you is amazing and beautiful-- or shut up about it. Or shut up about it.
我知道这听起来很蠢，因为谁在乎脚趾是什么形状？但你确实希望你深爱的人认为你身上的每一部分都是迷人而美丽的——或者对此闭嘴。或者对此闭嘴。
Maybe they're ugly. I don't know. Now that I'm looking at them-- I don't know. My big toe is definitely square.
也许它们很难看。我不知道。现在我看着它们——我不知道。我的大脚趾确实是方的。
When I get shy kids, one of the things I do with them is I try to give them permission to make fun of me.
当我遇到害羞的孩子时，我做的其中一件事就是试着给他们开玩笑戏弄我的许可。
This is a fifth grade teacher named Matthew Dicks, who is either the bravest or the most foolhardy man in America.
这是一位名叫马修·迪克斯的五年级老师，他要么是美国最勇敢的人，要么是最鲁莽的人。
And they often come out of  their shells by becoming the person who can taunt the teacher.
他们往往通过成为那个可以嘲弄老师的人而走出自己的壳。
That sounds very dangerous.
听起来很危险。
It is. I mean, you have to teach them where the line is. And sometimes I don't know where the line is either.
确实。我是说，你必须教他们界限在哪里。有时连我自己都不知道界限在哪里。
A few years ago, there was a girl in his class, very shy. And she got the nod that it was OK for her to make fun of Matthew if she wanted.
几年前，他班上有个女孩，非常害羞。她得到了可以嘲弄马修的许可。
So one day she came in, and she just walked in very casually. And she looked at me and she said, hi, Jerry. And I looked at her and I said, Jerry? And she said, never mind. And she just walked away.
所以有一天她进来了，走得很随意。她看着我说，嗨，杰里。我看着她说，杰里？她说，没事。然后就走开了。
And I knew she was setting me up for some joke. And it went on for days. Every time she'd walk by me, she'd say, hey Jerry, how's it going?
我知道她是在给我下套。这持续了好几天。每次她从我身边走过，她都会说，嘿，杰里，怎么样？
And so finally, after about a week, I couldn't take it anymore. And she came in one morning and she said, how you doing, Jerry? And I said, fine, who is Jerry? And she said, Jerry's your bald spot.
所以最后，大约一周后，我实在受不了了。一天早上她进来，她说，你好吗，杰里？我说，很好，谁是杰里？她说，杰里是你的秃顶。
Yikes.
天哪。
And I tried to play it off like, I don't have a bald spot. Go sit down. Give me a break. Ha ha. That was, like, the most ridiculous week-long joke I've ever heard in my life. But as soon as my kids left the room to go to gym, I ran to the bathroom, and I leaned over the sink. And at the very top of my head, I had a bald spot that I had no idea about.
我试图掩饰说，我没有秃顶。去坐下。饶了我吧。哈哈。那是我这辈子听过的最荒谬的长达一周的笑话。但当我的学生们离开教室去上体育课时，我跑到洗手间，俯身在洗手池上。在我的头顶处，真的有一块我根本不知道的秃顶。
Can I ask a logistical question? How does a fifth grader spot the top of your head?
我可以问个逻辑问题吗？五年级的学生怎么会看到你的头顶？
Oh. So in my classroom, I teach some Shakespeare to my students. And we have a stage in my classroom. I built a stage with curtains and lighting and everything. So if you're standing on my stage in my classroom, you can look down on me.
哦。在我的教室里，我给学生们教一些莎士比亚的东西。我的教室里有一个舞台。我搭了一个带有幕布、灯光和一切设施的舞台。所以如果你站在我的舞台上，你就能俯视我。
Now, you can say that Matthew brought this on himself. He gives some students permission to make fun of him, and he built a stage where students can peer down at him in judgment. But even if he did none of that, he's still a sitting duck for this exact kind of critical gaze.
现在，你可以说这是马修自找的。他给了一些学生嘲弄他的许可，他还搭了一个舞台，让学生们可以审视地俯视他。但即使他没做那些事，他依然是这种审视目光的活靶子。
You have 20 people-- you have 20 students, would you say?
你有 20 个人——你说有 20 个学生？
Yeah, between 20 and 30 every year.
是啊，每年在 20 到 30 个人之间。
OK, so between 20 and 30 people looking at you all day, every work day, and just taking stock of you.
好吧，也就是说每天工作时间都有 20 到 30 个人在盯着你看，并对你进行审视。
Yes, it's constant. I had pinkeye a couple of weeks ago. The kids knew I had pinkeye before I did, you know, because they just stare at you all day. And they see any sort of minute change in you. You know, you're really the only thing they look at for a great majority of the day.
是的，一直都是这样。我几周前得了红眼病。孩子们比我先知道，你知道，因为他们整天盯着你看。他们能看出你任何细微的变化。你知道，在一天的大部分时间里，你确实是他们唯一看的东西。
So they notice these little things. If I get a new shirt, they immediately notice. Everything that changes about me, they notice right away.
所以他们注意到了这些小事。如果我穿了一件新衬衫，他们马上就会注意到。关于我的一切变化，他们都会立刻注意到。
Today on the radio show, I, Nancy "Yellow Neck" Updike bring you stories about people facing the unexpected moment of realizing how other people see them, what that means, and what in God's name to do about it. Today's show "Is That What I Look Like?" Prepare to learn the truth. Plus, a special guest appearance that will surprise and delight you. Stay with us.
今天在电台节目中，我，南希·“黄脖子”·厄普代克，将为你带来一些故事，讲述人们在面对意想不到的时刻，意识到别人是如何看待他们，那意味着什么，以及到底该怎么办。今天的节目是“我看起来是那个样子吗？”准备好了解真相吧。另外，还有一个会让你感到惊喜和愉悦的特别嘉宾。请继续收听。
Act One, Blunt Force. Domingo Martinez has this story about a vision in Brownsville, Texas. Here's Domingo.
第一幕，直截了当的打击。多明戈·马丁内斯讲述了这个关于德克萨斯州布朗斯维尔的愿景的故事。请听多明戈的讲述。
When I was 16, I realized as far as my family went, school was considered my time, which meant I couldn't be pressed into labor by my father or grandmother. They were farm workers, and they made no claim on my time when I was supposed to be in school. So I learned to take advantage of this.
我 16 岁时意识到，就我们家而言，学校被认为是我的时间，这意味着父亲或祖母不能强迫我劳动。他们是农场工人，当我知道该在学校时，他们不会占用我的时间。所以我学会了利用这一点。
I'd make it to school before 7:30 AM, either by school bus or my mother's Taurus, and then wait out options for escape. By my sophomore year, this kid named Tony Garcia had become my primary friend. Tony was nearly 19 and only a junior, but he didn't seem all that bad because he had good parents and an even better little brother, who was about to lap him at graduation.
我会在早上 7:30 之前通过校车或我母亲的金牛座汽车赶到学校，然后等待逃跑的机会。到了高二，这个叫托尼·加西亚的家伙成了我的主要朋友。托尼快 19 岁了才上高二，但他看起来并不坏，因为他有很好的父母，还有一个即将要在毕业时超过他的更棒的弟弟。
Together, Tony and I would find ways to while away the hours by doing anything other than attending class before we had to report home again. We were big fans of Huckleberry Finn and Tom Sawyer, and we believed we were continuing a long celebrated American tradition by ditching class and getting stoned, a fantasy combination of Mark Twain and Hunter S. Thompson. But really, we were just lazy and looking for a good time.
我和托尼会想方设法消磨时间，做除了上课之外的任何事，直到我们不得不报告回家。我们是《哈克贝利·费恩历险记》和《汤姆·索亚历险记》的忠实粉丝，我们相信通过逃课和吸食大麻，我们是在延续一种备受推崇的美国传统，这是一种马克·吐温和亨特·S·汤普森风格的幻想结合。但说实话，我们只是懒惰，想找点乐子。
The skipping itself was not a problem. The problem was taking care of our grades and absences on our report cards before they reached our parents. And it was actually Tony who initiated me into the trade that I'd eventually pursue, graphic design. But in this early stage in high school, it was plain and simple forgery. There was no design in what we were doing.
逃课本身不是问题。问题是在成绩单传到父母手中之前处理好我们的成绩和缺勤记录。实际上是托尼引导我进入了那个我最终从事的行业：平面设计。但在高中早期，那只是明目张胆的伪造。我们所做的一切毫无设计可言。
It was Tony who placed the first X-Acto knife I ever held in my hands, and immediately I felt an overwhelming sense of possibility holding that little penknife. We'd intercept the report cards when they came in the mail. And then Tony took careful pains to explain this whole process to me, his flunky-- a term that came uncomfortably close to becoming literal-- over the photocopier in the library, feeding dimes into the machine like he was playing slots, in search of a copy that didn't blur or show the incisions in the original.
是托尼把我手中拿的第一把美工刀递给了我，那一刻，拿着那把小折刀，我感受到了巨大的可能性。当成绩单寄来时，我们会拦截它。然后托尼费尽心思地向我——他的跟班，一个几乎要变成现实的称呼——解释整个过程，在图书馆的复印机旁，像玩老虎机一样往机器里塞硬币，寻找一张没有模糊、没留下刀痕的复印件。
Look, man, he said through his trendy and tinted John Lennon glasses, a wanker style even then, you've just got to remove the two from the 23 absences and then lighten the reproduction, and now you've got three absences in first period instead of 23. Now take the eight from the 48, move the four over, and put the eight in front of that, and now you have a B in Spanish instead of an F.
听着，伙计，他戴着那种时髦的约翰·列侬眼镜说，即使在当时看来也是一种装腔作势的风格，你只需要把 23 次缺勤中的“2”去掉，然后调浅复印效果，现在第一节课的缺勤次数就从 23 次变成了 3 次。现在把 48 分中的“8”拿走，把“4”移过去，把“8”放到前面，现在你的西班牙语成绩就从 F 变成了 B。
Oh, I said, in total understanding, a big smile growing on my face. Give a man a ride, he skips for a day. Teach him how to forge--
哦，我说，完全理解，脸上露出了大大的笑容。给一个人搭车，他就能逃课一天。教他伪造——
It was ridiculously shortsighted, sure. But at that age, I never thought further than the immediate threat. Simply convincing my mother everything was quiet at school was enough for me. Dealing with school records and the larger consequences of robbing myself of even a substandard education, all that I would face at a later date-- and certainly have.
这当然短视得可笑。但在那个年纪，我从没想过眼前的威胁之外的事。只要能让母亲确信学校里一切正常，对我来说就足够了。处理学校记录和剥夺自己受教育权带来的更严重的后果，所有这些我以后都会面对——而且确实面对了。
Tony would usually borrow his mother's car for our expeditions, a blue Oldsmobile Delta 88. We'd leave school and drive to South Padre Island, a resort town at the end of a 28 mile highway that felt much more cosmopolitan than Brownsville, Texas, ever could. We did that drive, back and forth, three or four times a day, listening to Led Zeppelin, nodding our heads in unison with whomever else was stoned or drunk in the car.
托尼通常会借他母亲的车去探险，一辆蓝色的奥兹莫比尔 Delta 88。我们离开学校，驱车前往南帕德里岛，一个 28 英里公路尽头的度假小镇，它感觉比布朗斯维尔现代得多。我们来回跑，每天三四次，听着齐柏林飞艇乐队的音乐，和车里其他吸毒或喝醉的人一起点头。
My junior year and his senior year, Tony's parents bought him a Dodge Daytona. It was the year he would most assuredly graduate, they felt, and it was a chance for him to develop responsibility. In the mornings, the minute my mother would drop me off at school and disappear around the corner, Tony would drive around and park right in front of the school to pick me up, right in front of everybody. Dude, you gotta come skipping with me today, he'd say.
高三那年，托尼高四，他父母给他买了一辆道奇戴托纳。他们觉得那一定是他毕业的一年，这是他培养责任感的机会。每天早上，我母亲送我到学校后刚一消失在拐角处，托尼就会开着车在学校门口转悠，把我接走，就在所有人面前。嘿，伙计，你今天得跟我去逃课，他说。
But on one particular morning late in 1988, I balk. Nah, Tony. I gotta go back to class today, I protest. It's Thursday, and I haven't been since last week.
但在 1988 年末的一个特殊早晨，我犹豫了。不，托尼。我今天得回去上课，我抗议道。今天是星期四，我从上周起就没去过了。
Look, he says, I got two signed reentry slips. I can get you back in tomorrow or next week. It's not a problem. And I found a new place to get killer weed. Finding pot was always a problem, so when Tony said he found someone new, and it wasn't one of the morons who hung out by the tennis courts before school, I was intrigued.
听着，他说，我有两张签了字的复课单。我明天或下周能让你回去。没问题。而且我找到了一个买高纯度大麻的新地方。找大麻一直是个问题，所以当托尼说他找到了新货源，而且不是那些在学校网球场旁游荡的白痴时，我很感兴趣。
We first drive to a housing project east of school, where a woman sold $2 quarts of Budweiser out of her living room from a cooler to anyone with money, no questions asked. We buy a couple of quarts and smoke the last half-joint Tony has on the way to his new killer weed supplier. I was getting a bit high when I began to recognize the route he was taking and was then thoroughly taken aback when he drove right into my grandmother's driveway.
我们先开车去学校东边的一个廉价房区，那里有个女人从客厅的冷藏箱里卖 2 美元的百威啤酒，给任何有钱人，不问缘由。我们买了几瓶，在去他那个高纯度大麻供应商的路上一路上抽完了托尼剩下的半根烟。我开始有点上头了，当我认出他走的路线时，他直接开进了我祖母的车道，我彻底惊呆了。
I couldn't understand why. It just didn't make sense. This was the same driveway my family Pontiac would regularly pull into after church on Sundays when I was growing up in the late 1970s-- my mother's mother's house in downtown Brownsville. I was, I think the term is, unnerved.
我无法理解为什么。这根本说不通。这就是 70 年代末我长大后，周日去完教堂后我们家的庞蒂亚克车经常开进来的车道——我在布朗斯维尔市中心的祖母家。我觉得，我想这个词是，很不安。
My two uncles, Johnny and Abel, were working on a '79 Camaro when Tony drives up and parks, hood to hood, with their car. The hood was up, and they were both leaning into the guts of the engine, their heads popped up like bearded biker prairie dogs.
我的两个叔叔，约翰尼和阿贝尔，正在修理一辆 79 年款的科迈罗，这时托尼开过来，头对头地停在他们的车旁。引擎盖开着，他们两个都探进引擎里，脑袋像长胡子的草原土拨鼠一样露出来。
I sat frozen in the passenger seat, uncertain what to do next. Tony, noticing that I was startled, tells me to be cool, to chill out. These guys look mean, but they're all right. Anyways, he says as he's getting out of the driver's side, they're kind of dumb, but they got great weed.
我僵在副驾驶座上，不知道接下来该怎么办。托尼注意到我受惊了，让我冷静，放松。这些家伙看起来很凶，但他们没问题。总之，他说着推开驾驶座门，他们有点傻，但他们有很棒的大麻。
Didn't I know it. Abel and Johnny had a long history with local biker gangs, even a rumored affiliation with the Hell's Angels. They could get drugs nobody else could in this town. And as a result, they were total burnouts, hardly capable of cogent speech patterns in either English or Spanish. They landed in jail as often as other people attended church.
我太知道了。阿贝尔和约翰尼与当地摩托车帮派有很长的历史，甚至有传闻说他们与地狱天使帮有联系。他们能搞到镇上其他人搞不到的毒品。结果，他们彻底堕落了，几乎没法进行连贯的英语或西班牙语对话。他们进监狱的频率和别人去教堂的频率差不多。
But what they lacked in brains they certainly made up in brawn-- not that they'd tear apart a teenager like Tony or me, not in the daylight anyway. They had a code about that sort of thing. But if they felt cheated, they'd have taken a tire iron to my head long before they recognized me as their nephew. They were that burned out.
但他们脑子里的缺失绝对是用蛮力弥补了——并不是说他们会像撕碎托尼或我这样的青少年，至少在大白天不会。他们对此有一套准则。但如果他们觉得被骗了，在认出我是他们外甥之前，他们早就用撬棍砸我的头了。他们已经堕落到那个地步了。
So I sit there paralyzed in the front seat, side B of Houses of the Holy playing on Tony's cassette deck. And because it's hot, the AC is blasting. So once Tony closes the door, I can't hear anything. I just watch as this terrifying pantomime plays out before me.
所以我瘫坐在前排座位上，播放着托尼卡带机里的《圣屋》B 面。因为很热，空调在狂吹。所以托尼关上门后，我什么也听不见。我只是看着眼前这出恐怖的哑剧上演。
Tony, half-shaven in his preppy clothes, closes a door and hails his greeting. My uncle Abel, already brain dead from years of sniffing paint, narrows his eyes in suspicion and then noiselessly responds with a nodding. Hey.
托尼穿着预科生服装，半剃着胡子，关上车门大声打招呼。我的叔叔阿贝尔，因多年吸入油漆已经脑死亡，警惕地眯起眼睛，无声地回应地点了点头。嘿。
Tony averts eye contact, looking anywhere but directly at Abel for fear that Abel might charge like a gorilla. Abel gives him a suspicious, quick upward jut of the chin that says, did I sell to you before? Who told you I got weed?
托尼避开了眼神交流，看向别处，生怕阿贝尔像大猩猩一样冲过来。阿贝尔快速而怀疑地抬了下下巴，意思好像在说，我之前卖给你过吗？谁告诉你我有大麻？
Tony lowers his head in quiet confidence, talking to Abel. Then my uncle Johnny nods towards me in the car, says something to Tony. They all turn to look at me. My eyes go wide, a big smile on my face, nodding. Tony says something, and then they all laugh together.
托尼低着头，小声而自信地和阿贝尔交谈。然后我叔叔约翰尼朝车里的我点点头，对托尼说了些什么。他们都转过头看着我。我睁大眼睛，脸上带着大大的笑容，点头回应。托尼说了些什么，然后他们一起大笑起来。
Led Zeppelin still plays loudly in the car. Then my uncle Abel slaps Tony on the back and leads   him around to the back of the car, right where I am. Johnny stands there too, looking at me and smiling, makes his index finger and thumb into a mock roach, and laughs. I mimic the roach back. Even now, he doesn't recognize me.
齐柏林飞艇的音乐在车里依然大声播放。然后我叔叔阿贝尔拍了拍托尼的背，把他带到车后，就在我坐的地方。约翰尼也站在那，看着我微笑，把食指和拇指比作一个假装的烟头，大笑起来。我学着他的样子回敬他。即使到了现在，他还没认出我来。
Then Tony and Abel emerge around the other side of the car with Tony's hand in his pocket, and both of them are laughing like they're suddenly old friends. Tony turns and waves, and both Johnny and Abel wave back. The door opens, and Tony says, dude, we got a big joint for $2, as he gets in the driver's seat.
然后托尼和阿贝尔从车另一侧冒出来，托尼的手插在口袋里，两人笑得像突然成了老朋友。托尼转过身挥手，约翰尼和阿贝尔也挥手回应。门开了，托尼坐进驾驶座说，伙计，我们花 2 美元搞到了一根大烟卷。
This has freaked me out to no end. Abel and Johnny are both waving, making the universal roach-smoking signal as we drive off, and it leaves me feeling really, really conflicted. The car slips up the southernmost terminus of Highway 77, and we head north from urban Brownsville to drive around as we smoke the joint.
这彻底吓坏我了。我们开走时，阿贝尔和约翰尼都在挥手，比着那个全世界通用的抽烟手势，这让我感到非常非常矛盾。车滑向 77 号公路的最南端终点，我们往北开，一边绕行一边抽那个烟卷。
Tony lights it, and it starts burning purple. Purple Haze, he says, and then follows it with his characteristic, ahh!
托尼把它点着了，它开始冒紫烟。紫色阴霾，他说，然后接着他标志性的笑声，啊！
Hey man, I say, I'm kind of scared about smoking this. I've never seen one burn this color. Aw dude, says Tony, don't worry about it. Those guys got killer weed, man. They're, like, bikers or something. It's probably laced with something. That's why it was $2.
嘿，伙计，我说，我有点害怕抽这个。我从没见过烟冒这种颜色。噢伙计，托尼说，别担心。那些家伙有高质量的大麻。他们是摩托车手什么的。这可能是掺了什么东西。这就是为什么它只要 2 美元。
This idea sounds appealing to Tony. It scares the [BLEEP] out of me. We're both getting incredibly high.
这个主意对托尼来说很有吸引力。但我被吓惨了。我们俩都变得兴奋到了极点。
Hey man, says Tony, wouldn't it be messed up if, like, when you were high, your hair went into, like, a huge orange Afro, and the higher you were, the bigger your Afro got? You couldn't go anywhere, because people would be like, man, that guy's stoned.
嘿，伙计，托尼说，如果在你嗨的时候，你的头发变成一个巨大的橙色爆炸头，而且你越嗨，爆炸头就越大，那会怎么样？你哪儿也去不了，因为人们会说，伙计，那家伙嗨大了。
I sit there in Tony's car and think about my uncles, Johnny and Abel. Johnny had been stabbed in the back with a flat-headed screwdriver about a month earlier in a street fight. His lung had been punctured, and my grandmother said you could hear whistling every time he inhaled. He wouldn't go to the hospital to get it treated for three days.
我坐在托尼的车里，想起我的叔叔约翰尼和阿贝尔。约翰尼一个月前在街头斗殴中背部被一把平头螺丝刀刺伤。他的肺部被刺穿了，我祖母说你能听到他每次吸气时都有哨声。他坚持了三天都没去医院治疗。
We're halfway done with the joint when I say to Tony, hey man, I don't want to get stoned anymore. All right, well, put it out, Tony says, nodding his head back and forth to Zeppelin.
我们抽了一半烟时，我对托尼说，嘿，伙计，我不想再嗨了。好吧，那把它掐掉吧，托尼说，随着齐柏林飞艇的音乐摇头晃脑。
Tony's left hand is fingering chords into the neck of an imaginary guitar as he's driving. I watch his fingers move for a few seconds, suspended and twisting around like they're an overturned King crab, and I can find no correlation with the chords in the song.
托尼的左手在开车时假装弹奏吉他，手指在指板上舞动。我看着他的手指晃动了几秒钟，悬空扭动，就像一只翻过来的帝王蟹，我找不到这和歌里的和弦有任何联系。
Man, I mean I don't want to smoke pot anymore, I say to him. I don't want to skip class anymore. I want to get back to school. Not today, but, like, in general. I don't want to feel like this anymore, like I'm doing something bad. I feel like this all the time now, dirty.
伙计，我是说我不想再抽大麻了，我对他讲。我不想再逃课了。我想回到学校。不是今天，而是，总的来说。我不想再有这种感觉了，像我在做坏事。我现在一直都有这种感觉，很脏。
Look at that really [BLEEP] small house over there. We were on an overpass, and I just noticed a house beneath us in the Brownsville Country Club, about a quarter of the size of the houses surrounding it. Tony starts laughing so hard I have to make him focus back on the driving, but then I laugh along with him.
看那边那栋非常[哔]小的房子。我们在立交桥上，我刚注意到我们下方布朗斯维尔乡村俱乐部里的一栋房子，只有周围房子四分之一那么大。托尼笑得太厉害了，我不得不让他集中精神开车，但随后我也跟着他笑了起来。
You're stoned, he tells me. Yeah, I say. I'm way stoned.
你嗨了，他告诉我。是啊，我说。我嗨透了。
Hey, man, I say a little later-- we're driving back to South Padre Island now-- you know those guys we bought weed from earlier today? The bikers, Tony says. That was my grandmother's house, man. Those are my uncles, I say, even though I'm really embarrassed by it.
嘿，伙计，过了一会儿我说——我们现在正开回南帕德里岛——你知道我们今天早些时候买大麻的那家伙吗？那些摩托车手，托尼说。那是我祖母的房子，伙计。那些是我叔叔，我说，尽管我为此感到非常尴尬。
Tony finds this befuddling. He can't figure out what the bikers were doing at my grandmother's house. Those dudes were my mom's brothers, man, my uncles, I explain.
托尼觉得这很令人困惑。他搞不懂为什么那些摩托车手会在我祖母家。伙计，那些是我妈的兄弟，是我叔叔，我解释道。
Tony is laughing so hard he has to pull over to the side of the road. His laughing is infectious, and I find myself laughing right along with him, laughing harder than I have laughed in a really, really long time. But I'm feeling utterly beyond redemption on the inside, like I had just done something today that I couldn't take back, like my course was now set.
托尼笑得不得不把车停在路边。他的笑声很有感染力，我发现自己也跟着他大笑起来，笑得比我很久很久以来笑得都开心。但在内心深处，我感到一种彻底无法救赎的感觉，好像我今天做了一件无法挽回的事，好像我的人生轨迹从此定型了。
Domingo Martinez, reading a story from his memoir, The Boy Kings of Texas . He's got a new book coming out this fall called My Heart is a Drunken Compass .
多明戈·马丁内斯，朗读他的回忆录《德州的男孩国王》中的一个片段。他今年秋天要出一本新书，叫《我的心是醉酒的指南针》。
[MUSIC - "WRONG CROWD" BY PRINCE GEORGE]
[音乐 - “错误的群体” 作者：乔治王子]
Act Two, One Life to Live. Having a blind spot about yourself is not the end of the world, depending on what it is and how big it is. Sometimes that's all hard to tell, though, without outside eyes. This next story we changed some of the names. It's a complicated situation that's still unfolding.
第二幕，仅剩的人生。对自己有盲点并不是世界末日，具体取决于那是什么以及它有多大。不过，没有旁人的视角，有时很难判断。对于下一个故事，我们改动了一些名字。这是一个复杂且仍在发展的情况。
Sarah got into a bad car accident last year. She was in a coma with a traumatic brain injury, and her doctors thought she might die. But after 52 days in the coma, she woke up. Our producer Miki Meek tells the story of what happened next.
莎拉去年出了一场严重的车祸。她陷入昏迷，大脑严重受损，医生以为她可能会死。但在昏迷 52 天后，她醒了过来。我们的制作人米基·米克讲述了接下来的故事。
Waking up from a coma doesn't happen all at once. It's a slow process, like coming awake over months, sometimes even years. For Sarah, it took almost three months before she could talk well enough to have a simple conversation and another four months for her to get out of the hospital and go home to live with her parents. She still needed a lot of care, but she was really excited to spend time with her husband Billy. He had a birthday party.
从昏迷中醒来不是瞬间发生的。这是一个缓慢的过程，就像在几个月甚至几年里慢慢醒来一样。对莎拉来说，花了近三个月的时间，她才能说话进行简单的对话，又花了四个月才出院回家，和父母住在一起。她仍然需要很多照料，但她真的很高兴能和丈夫比利待在一起。他有一个生日派对。
And that's when I just said, will you give me a kiss, please? And he was like, mm-- maybe I can give you one of these. And he turned my head and kissed me on the cheek. So I was hurt and kind of frustrated and annoyed.
然后我就说了，你能吻我一下吗，拜托？他当时就像，嗯——也许我可以给你这个。他转过我的头，亲了我的脸颊。所以我感到受伤，有点沮丧和恼火。
Sarah thought maybe Billy was just worried about getting her sick, so she made a comment about it to her stepmom Alice when they got in the car to go home.
莎拉以为比利只是担心传染她生病，所以当他们坐车回家时，她跟继母爱丽丝说了这件事。
I said, I think that Billy is worried he'll get me sick because he won't kiss me. And that's when she said--
我说，我觉得比利担心会传染我，因为他不肯亲我。然后她说了——
We need to talk. And that's when I had the impression she was ready. I said, it feels different. Being with Billy, it feels different. She's like, yeah, it does. I was, like, well, that's because you guys aren't married anymore. You're divorced.
我们需要谈谈。那一刻，我觉得她准备好了。我说，感觉不对劲。和比利在一起，感觉不一样了。她说，是啊，确实不对劲。我说，哦，那是因为你们已经不再是夫妻了。你们离婚了。
Sarah had forgotten the entire two years before her accident. She'd forgotten the fact that during those two years she had fallen out of love with her husband and divorced him. Here's what she did remember-- she remembered her wedding day in 1998. She was 17, and Billy was 20. She had just found out she was pregnant with twins.
莎拉忘记了事故发生前整整两年的事情。她忘记了在这两年里，她已经不再爱丈夫并和他离婚的事实。她记得的是——她记得 1998 年的结婚那天。她 17 岁，比利 20 岁。她刚刚发现自己怀了双胞胎。
Sarah remembered the house where their family grew from two kids to four. It was in a small town out west, just down the street from her parents. She remembered family camping trips on the weekends, baseball games, and dinner together every night-- 13 years of memories like that.
莎拉记得他们家庭从两个孩子增加到四个孩子的那个家。它在西部的一个小镇上，离她父母家只有几条街。她记得周末的家庭露营，棒球比赛，还有每天晚上的晚餐——像那样的 13 年回忆。
It wasn't always perfect. Billy joined the National Guard and was gone a lot. He served in Iraq. Sometimes he had a bad temper. But they loved each other.
并不总是完美的。比利参加了国民警卫队，经常不在家。他在伊拉克服役。有时他的脾气很坏。但他们彼此相爱。
There was a lot more to the story, and her family really wanted to sit her down and fill all those memories back in for her. But the doctors told them they had to be cautious. Let things come up naturally for Sarah. Let her brain set the pace. That was the best way for her to recover.
故事远不止于此，她的家人真的很想坐下来，把所有的记忆都补回给她。但医生告诉他们必须谨慎。让莎拉自然地想起。让她的脑子自己定节奏。那是她康复的最佳方式。
So when her stepmom told her about her divorce, Sarah was shocked and confused. And for her, there was only one question.
所以当继母告诉她离婚的事时，莎拉震惊且困惑。对她来说，只有一个问题。
Do you think it's too late? Do you think I can get him back?
你觉得太晚了吗？你觉得我还能追回他吗？
The next day, Sarah called up Billy and asked him to come over.
第二天，莎拉打电话叫比利过来。
And I just flat out said, my stepmom says that we got divorced, and I'm hoping that you'll take me back. And when I first said it, then he did smile. But then he got kind of stern and more serious.
我就直截了当地说了，我继母说我们离婚了，但我希望你能跟我复婚。当我刚说出口时，他确实笑了。但后来他变得有点严厉和严肃了。
And I told her, well, I need to take my time.
我对她说，好吧，我需要慢慢来。
When one person loses two years, it forces everyone else around them to go back in time too. Billy had never wanted the divorce, but he understood why Sarah left him. She had come to despise him during those two years she had forgotten. And now here was the old Sarah again, the one who still loved him, calling him regularly.
当一个人失去了两年记忆，这迫使周围所有的人也跟着回到过去。比利从来都不想要离婚，但他理解莎拉为什么要离开他。在她忘记的那两年里，她已经开始鄙视他了。现在，那个旧的莎拉又回来了，那个依然爱他的莎拉，经常打电话给他。
Like, hey Billy, you know, it's really good to hear your voice. And I was like, well, that's awesome. It's really good to hear you too, you know?
就像，嘿比利，你知道，听到你的声音真好。我说，哇，太棒了。听到你的声音也很好，你知道吗？
She was like, Billy, I love you so much. The "so" was  always-- that stood out. Yeah, it was weird. I'm not going to lie to you, it was like, oh my goodness. This was tough. I was in a spot where I'm like, oh, why? Why are you telling me this?
她会说，比利，我太爱你了。那个“太”字总是——很突出。是啊，很奇怪。我不骗你，当时我的感觉就像，哦，天哪。这太难了。我当时处在一个像，哦，为什么？你为什么要跟我说这个？
This is not what I want to hear, you know. And then the other part of me is telling me, like, yes, this is what I want to hear.
这不是我想听的，你知道。然后我内心的另一部分在告诉我，比如，是的，这就是我想听的。
As much as Billy wanted to hear it, the rest of Sarah's family did not. She was falling back in love with a guy she wanted nothing to do with before her accident. Her sister Jessica remembers watching all of this with alarm.
尽管比利很想听，但莎拉的其他家人却不想。她正在重新爱上一个她在事故前根本不想再有任何瓜葛的家伙。她的妹妹杰西卡记得惊恐地看着这一切。
She would get this little schoolgirl look on her face and, like, bat her eyes, like a little teenager looking at their crush. And she's like, hi, Billy! And so I would just look at her so disgusted, just sitting there, zipping my mouth closed so that I don't say, you are divorced. You are divorced for a reason. Like, stop batting your eyes at him. You don't like him.
她脸上会露出那种小学生的表情，眨着眼睛，就像个看着暗恋对象的青春期女孩。她会说，嗨，比利！所以我只会厌恶地看着她，闭紧嘴巴，不让自己说，你们离婚了。你们离婚是有原因的。别再对他眨眼了。你根本不喜欢他。
Sarah's family remembered very clearly what Sarah herself did not, the many reasons why she had left Billy, why she was living with them now, not him. Her daughter Kristen recalled getting into an argument with her dad. The situation escalated, like it always did. As Kristen was telling me the story, she pointed to a patched up hole in the basement wall.
莎拉的家人非常清楚莎拉自己不记得的事，她离开比利的许多原因，她为什么现在和他们住在一起，而不是和他住在一起。她的女儿克里斯汀记得和爸爸吵过架。情况总是会升级。当克里斯汀给我讲这个故事时，她指了指地下室墙上一个修补过的洞。
That hole in the wall was my mom's breaking point. My dad tried to swing at me, and he barely missed my head. And I just remember my mom was so quiet that night. Like, she didn't want to go upstairs. She didn't want to go find my dad. She was scared.
墙上的那个洞是我妈妈的爆发点。我爸爸想打我，他差点没打到我的头。我只记得那天晚上我妈妈很安静。就像，她不想上楼。她不想去找我爸爸。她很害怕。
And she looked  at the wall, and she was looking at me. And I was sitting on the ground crying. I yelled at her that night, divorce him. And one day she wrote him a letter, and when he came home from work, he found the letter that said, you need to pack up your stuff and leave. My mom had had it.
她看着墙，然后看着我。我坐在地上哭。那天晚上我冲她吼，和他离婚。有一天她给他写了一封信，当他下班回家时，他发现了那封信，上面写着，你必须收拾行李离开。我妈受够了。
Sarah didn't remember this moment of Billy punching a hole in the wall until she had a conversation with her bishop at church. She and Billy had gone to this bishop for counseling when they were married. Now she was going back to him on a detective mission of sorts. She knew she had left Billy, but maybe the bishop could help her remember why.
莎拉不记得比利在墙上打洞的那个时刻，直到她和教堂的主教谈话。他们在婚姻期间曾找这位主教做咨询。现在她正作为某种侦探任务回去找他。她知道她离开了比利，但也许主教能帮她回忆起原因。
And he was like, you were tired. You were so tired of the emotional abuse. He punched a hole in the wall. And I remembered it instantly. And I thought, oh yeah, I can remember that. And it makes sense as to why I would have divorced him with all the things we were dealing with.
他说，你累了。你对情感虐待感到太累了。他在墙上打了个洞。我立刻就想起来了。我想，哦对了，我能记得那个。而且考虑到我们处理的所有事情，我为什么会和他离婚也就说得通了。
So this is what Sarah's life is like right now. Memories of her and Billy's bad times are starting to pop back into her mind. Some are big, like the time he threw scissors at her and cut her under her eye. Others are small. There's no particular order to them. She says she gets a new memory every two weeks or so.
这就是莎拉现在的生活状态。关于她和比利糟糕时光的记忆开始在她脑海中浮现。有些是大事，比如他向她扔剪刀，划伤她眼睛下方。有些是小事。它们没有特定的顺序。她说她大约每两周就会有一个新的记忆。
When it comes to me, it's just like a light gets switched on in my head. So it goes from darkness and nothing being there to all of a sudden something is there. Like, a recent one is that he would take my phone and read through my phone all the time because he thought that the only reason I wanted a divorce was because I wanted to date other men.
对于我来说，就像脑子里开了一盏灯。所以它从黑暗和空无一物，突然之间就有了东西。比如，最近一个记忆是，他总是拿走我的手机翻看，因为他认为我想要离婚的唯一原因是我想要和别的男人约会。
While we were talking, another memory appeared right in front of me. This one was about how by the end of their marriage, they were going out of their way just to be mean to each other. Sarah would tell Billy all the time that she liked her friends better than him.
在我们谈话时，另一个记忆就在我面前出现了。这一次是关于在婚姻结束时，他们是如何费尽心机去伤害对方的。莎拉总是告诉比利，她喜欢朋友胜过喜欢他。
I think I used to tell him that my friends were number one and that he was number two. And so I was definitely hurting his feelings. That was a memory that just barely came-- like, just now while we were talking.
我想我以前常告诉他，我的朋友是第一位，而他是第二位。所以我是绝对伤害了他的感情。那是刚刚才浮现出的记忆——就在刚才我们聊天的时候。
Sarah's biggest problem is that she knows her marriage got bad. She knows those facts. But she just can't remember the feelings-- the feelings of being so fed up that she stopped wanting to work it out with Billy. Not being able to access those feelings is one reason it's so hard to accept the decision she made back then. But there's another layer to the story.
莎拉最大的问题在于她知道婚姻变糟糕了。她知道那些事实。但她就是无法想起那些感觉——那种受够了，不再想和比利解决问题的感觉。无法触及那些感觉是她很难接受当时那个决定的原因之一。但故事还有另一面。
That guy she wanted to divorce has, by all accounts, changed. The before and after in Sarah's life was the accident. In Billy's it was the divorce. He was devastated by their break-up. He started reading self-help books, going to church, and for a while he was seeing three different counselors.
那个她想要离婚的家伙，据各方面所说，已经变了。莎拉生活的前后分界线是事故。比利的则是离婚。他对他们的分手感到崩溃。他开始读自助书籍，去教堂，有一段时间他同时看三个不同的咨询师。
Everything was just angry. It was just-- I was always mad. So I would just react to everything.
一切都只有愤怒。就是——我总是很生气。所以我对一切都反应过激。
You know, some of the stuff that just sort of came up is, you know, grabbing your daughter and putting her up against the wall and punching a hole.
你知道，一些刚浮现出来的事情是，比如，抓住女儿把她推到墙上并打个洞。
I'll tell you this-- I will take full responsibility for that. I shouldn't have punched a wall. I shouldn't have, and I did. Of course that makes me regret it. I feel bad. I feel horrible. I feel-- I wish I would have listened more.
我告诉你——我会对此负全部责任。我不该打墙。我不该，但我确实做了。当然这让我后悔。我感到难过。我感到糟糕。我感到——我真希望我当时能多听听。
I wish I would have got the help I needed and admitted. And after I lost everything, that's the only time I really refocused and thought, wait a minute, I lost it all. Now I've got  to start over.
我真希望我当时能得到我需要的帮助并承认这一点。失去一切之后，那才是我真正重新审视并想，等等，我失去了一切。现在我必须从头开始。
Billy did start over, mainly by repairing his relationship with his kids. They've been living with Billy full-time since Sarah's accident, and it's going well. Their daughter Kristen says Billy's like a different person. He listens more now and wants to talk problems out.
比利确实从头开始了，主要是通过修复他和孩子们的关系。莎拉事故后，孩子们一直和比利全职住在一起，情况进行得很好。他们的女儿克里斯汀说比利简直换了一个人。他现在听得更多，也想把问题谈开。
Me and my dad are really close. Throughout time, after him and my mom got divorced, he figured out ways to control his anger. I mean, my dad's really good at keeping calm-- now. Now he is. And he's really good at handling situations with us.
我和我爸真的很亲。随着时间的推移，在他和我妈离婚后，他找到了控制自己愤怒的方法。我是说，我爸现在真的很擅长保持冷静。现在是的。他很擅长处理我们之间的情况。
And so I'm not saying I'm glad my mom wrecked. But I wouldn't trade anything because I like where we are now, because my dad wouldn't be living with us right now if she didn't wreck. And so I feel like I got to know my dad so much better.
所以我不是说我很高兴我妈出车祸了。但我什么都不会换，因为我喜欢我们现在的状态，因为如果她没出事，我爸现在就不会和我们住在一起。所以我觉得我更了解我爸爸了。
Is there any part of you that sometimes thinks, oh, maybe if they could stay this way, then maybe it  would work?
你内心有没有哪部分会想，哦，也许如果他们能保持这样，那么也许行得通？
So everything's really good between them right now. But I don't think that they'd be good as a married couple. And I probably won't ever think that, because I've seen the worst of them, and I've seen the best of them. And I still think that the worst of them has more control. Because what if they do go back to old habits and my dad does start to get mean again? I feel like it'd ruin what we built while she was gone.
所以他们现在一切都很好。但我认为他们不适合做夫妻。而且我可能永远不会那样想，因为我看过他们最糟糕的一面，也看过他们最好的一面。我依然认为最糟糕的一面占据更多控制权。因为如果他们又回到旧习惯，我爸又开始变坏了呢？我觉得这会毁了她在的时候我们建立的东西。
A few nights a week, Sarah and Billy go for these little drives around town in his truck and just talk about what it might be like if they got back together. They pass the church they went to when they were married and the park where they took their kids to play. These drives are like dates for them.
一周几个晚上，莎拉和比利会开着他的卡车在镇上兜兜风，谈谈如果他们复合会是什么样子。他们经过他们结婚时去过的教堂，和他们带孩子去玩的公园。这些车程对他们来说就像约会。
Kinda nice how things have gone. So it's like we get to start over, you know? It would be better for the kids if we could learn how to be a team. And I wasn't very good at being a team with you.
事情进行得真不错。所以就像我们有了重新开始的机会，你知道吗？如果我们能学会如何成为一个团队，这对孩子们会更好。但我以前不太擅长和你成为一个团队。
Neither was I.
我也不擅长。
Sarah's 33. Billy's 36. And they know everyone else thinks it would be crazy for them to get back together again. And it is crazy-- soap opera crazy. Sarah gets amnesia and forgets that she hated her husband so much that she divorced him. Meanwhile, the husband her daughter begged her to divorce has taken Sarah's place in the house. He's now the person who takes care of the children. He's even someone they trust.
莎拉 33 岁。比利 36 岁。他们知道其他所有人都认为他们复合会很疯狂。而且这确实很疯狂——像肥皂剧一样疯狂。莎拉失忆了，忘记了她曾经非常恨丈夫以至于和他离婚。与此同时，她女儿求她离婚的那个丈夫已经取代了莎拉在家的位置。他现在是照看孩子的人。他甚至成了孩子们信任的人。
Kind of feels like I was supposed to get in the wreck, because we learned a lot. Because I woke up not even remembering I was divorced. And so I had all those months in the hospital just thinking of how much I love you and how much I miss you, and--
感觉好像我本来就该出这场车祸，因为我们学到了很多。因为我醒来时甚至不记得我离婚了。所以我整整几个月在医院里只是想着我是多么爱你，我是多么想你，而且——
I was trying so hard to always work on not loving you. It didn't work.
我一直在努力不去爱你。这没用。
Couples who split up are usually facing a pile of bad memories so huge that there's no hope of digging their way out. Trying to talk about one wrongdoing sets off this chain reaction of anger and bitterness about all the other wrongdoings. But Sarah's accident lets her and Billy deal with one memory at a time, as they bubble up, usually in the mornings when she first wakes up.
分手的情侣通常面临一堆堆糟糕的记忆，大到没有挖出来的希望。试图谈论其中一件错事会引发关于其他所有错事的愤怒和痛苦的连锁反应。但莎拉的事故让她和比利可以一次处理一个记忆，随着它们冒出来，通常是在她刚醒来的早晨。
Sometimes I just lay in bed. And then the first person I talk to-- because I always decide when I have a memory, I've decided to bring it up to Billy every time.
有时我只是躺在床上。然后我谈话的第一个人——因为我总是决定当我有了记忆，我就决定每次都跟比利提一下。
And then how has he been responding to those?
那他对此有什么反应？
He's been good about it, just admitting what happened and apologizing and telling me that he'll be better.
他一直做得很好，只是承认发生了什么并道歉，告诉我他会变好。
And one thing I was wondering, when you guys were married, did you ever bring this up to him?
还有一件事我很好奇，你们结婚的时候，你有没有提过这些？
Not when we were married. Uh-uh. He used to would have never apologized for anything that he had done. And the good thing about me losing my memory is that we're able to talk about everything that comes up in a better way. It's less hurt and less powerful, you know what I mean?
我们结婚时没有。不。他过去从来不会为他做过的任何事道歉。我失忆的好处是，我们能够以更好的方式谈论所有冒出来的事。少了一些伤害，也没那么有杀伤力，你知道我的意思吗？
Sarah's changed too. She says she gets irritated easier now and can throw these tantrums she never had before. She's still learning to get around without a walker and to do small things, like organize her pills for the day. It's not clear when she can move out of her parents' house. They have legal guardianship over her.
莎拉也变了。她说她现在更容易生气，会发以前从没发过的脾气。她还在学习在没有助行器的情况下四处走动，做些小事，比如整理她一天的药片。不清楚她什么时候能从父母家搬走。他们拥有她的法定监护权。
And she goes back and forth about Billy. One day she told me, I'd marry that guy tomorrow if he asked. And other times, she's less sure. She knows divorcing Billy was the right decision back then. She just wants to make the right decision now.
她对比利反反复复。有一天她对我说，如果他开口，我明天就会嫁给他。而其他时候，她就不那么确定了。她知道当时和比利离婚是正确的决定。她只是想做出现在的正确决定。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, what the movie The Breakfast Club can teach you about parenting if you were in The Breakfast Club . That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
米基·米克是我们节目的制作人之一。接下来，如果看过电影《早餐俱乐部》，它能教你关于为人父母的道理。这在芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的节目继续后一分钟播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Nancy Updike, sitting in for Ira Glass who will be back next week. Every week, we choose a theme-- you know that-- and we present various stories on that theme. Today's show, "Is That What I Look Like?" Stories of seeing yourself through other people's eyes, whether you want to or not. And we're here at Act Three, which I think is going to be kind of a two-parter.
这里是《美国生活》。我是南希·厄普代克，为下周就要回来的艾拉·格拉斯代班。每周，我们都会选定一个主题——你知道的——然后我们呈现关于那个主题的各种故事。今天的节目是“我看起来是那个样子吗？”关于通过别人的眼睛看待自己的故事，无论你是否愿意。我们现在进行到第三幕，我想这会是一个两段式的部分。
Act Three-- Ben, do you want to do that part?
第三幕——本，你想做那部分吗？
Sure. Act Three, The Blunder Years.
没问题。第三幕，笨拙的岁月。
I'm talking to Ben Calhoun, one of the producers here. And he's got a small story. He's embarrassed to tell it, but I'm making him. So Ben.
我正在和我们的制作人本·卡尔霍恩谈话。他有一个小故事。他很尴尬说出来，但我逼他说了。所以，本。
Yeah?
怎么了？
Take us back. It's eight grade?
带我们回去。那是八年级？
Eighth grade. And I should just say, like, I played tuba. I was small. That was me. And definitely, like, zero attention from the girls in Roosevelt Middle School.
八年级。我应该先说，我吹大号。我很矮。那就是我。而且在罗斯福中学，女孩们绝对对我零关注。
I had this teacher, though, who-- her name was Miss Savage. She was the cool teacher.
不过我有个老师，她的名字叫萨维奇小姐。她是那个酷老师。
I bet.
我猜也是。
Yeah. She was younger than pretty much every teacher in the school. She was, like, into Jane's Addiction. And she was the rock and roll teacher, and all of the kids sort of, like, idolized her.
是的。她比学校里几乎所有的老师都年轻。她迷恋“简的沉迷”乐队。她是那个摇滚老师，所有的孩子都崇拜她。
And we are going in a G, PG direction with this, right? Just checking.
我们要往 G 或 PG 级方向讨论这个，对吧？我只是确认一下。
Yeah.
是的。
OK, continue.
OK，继续。
So there was just this one day when I'm just, like, standing in the classroom. And there was a crowd of girls that were standing around Miss Savage. And I have no idea what they were talking about.
有一天我正站在教室里。有一群女孩围在萨维奇小姐身边。我完全不知道她们在聊什么。
And Miss Savage is saying something. And then out of the blue, she points to me. I'm standing on the other side of the room. And she says, look out for that Ben Calhoun. He's going to be a heart breaker.
萨维奇小姐正在说什么。然后突然间，她指向我。我正站在房间另一边。她说，小心那个本·卡尔霍恩。他会是个伤心的人。
And did the girls turn and look?
然后女孩们都转过来看了吗？
It was like a crowd of faces pivoted like satellites and looked at me. And I was just like, I don't totally know what happened, but it feels like maybe my life might have changed just right then.
就像一群卫星一样的脸转过来看着我。我当时就像，我完全不知道发生了什么，但这感觉就像我的生活可能就在那一刻改变了。
And?
然后？
You mean, like, what--
你是说，什么——
Did it change? Yeah, yeah. Did the girls kind of start to notice?
改变了吗？是啊，是啊。女孩们开始注意到你了吗？
One girl in particular.
其中一个女孩特别注意到了。
That's all you need.
那你就只需要那个。
Yeah.
是啊。
And that really can be all you need to change your life when you're a teenager-- just one person who thinks you're great. Because chances are, your own sense of yourself is way off. A friend of a friend-- this is a woman in her 50s-- came across an old photo of herself as a teenager. And it'd been years since she'd seen any pictures of herself at that age.
当你还是个青少年时，那真的就是改变你人生所需要的全部——只需要一个人觉得你很棒。因为很有可能，你对自己感官的判断是大错特错的。一个朋友的朋友——这是一位 50 多岁的女士——偶然发现了一张她青少年时期的旧照片。那是她多年来第一次看到那个年纪自己的照片。
And she looked at them and thought, oh wait, I was pretty. I was pretty. It kind of floored her, because of course the girl in the pictures looked nothing like the way she thought of herself at the time. She said she wished she'd known it back then. It would have made a difference.
她看着它们想，哦等等，我当时很漂亮。我当时很漂亮。这有点让她震惊，因为照片里的女孩当然和她当时对自己认知的样子完全不像。她说她希望自己当时就知道。那会有所不同。
Lots of us have had that experience, looking at old family pictures or yearbooks, seeing things we never saw at the time. This next story is a very specialized case of that kind of thing. It's about the actress Molly Ringwald, who of course doesn't just have photos but movies-- beautifully shot, widescreen, full-length Hollywood films of herself as a teenager. She's the redhead, the star, in those three iconic '80s movies by John Hughes, Pretty in Pink , Sixteen Candles , and The Breakfast Club .
我们很多人都有过这种经历，看着旧的全家福或年鉴，看到了当时从未看到的东西。下一个故事是那种事情的一个非常专业的案例。它是关于女演员莫莉·林沃德的，她当然不仅仅有照片，还有电影——由约翰·休斯执导的那三部经典的 80 年代电影《粉红佳人》、《十六支蜡烛》和《早餐俱乐部》，她在里面担任主角，那个红头发的女孩。
Recently, she revisited one of those movies, not exactly by choice. And she talked to Ira Glass. Here's Ira.
最近，她重温了其中一部电影，并非完全出于自愿。她和艾拉·格拉斯聊了聊。请听艾拉的讲述。
I supposed it's not a big surprise that Molly Ringwald does not sit around watching old Molly Ringwald films. You know, she's seen them. She needs a big reason to go back to them.
莫莉·林沃德并不会坐着看旧的莫莉·林沃德电影，我想这并不奇怪。你知道，她看过它们。她需要一个很大的理由才会回去看。
And recently her daughter gave her a reason. Her daughter Mathilda is 10. And Mathilda wanted to see The Breakfast Club . Of course, 10 is a little young to see The Breakfast Club , but most of her friends had seen it.
最近她的女儿给了她一个理由。她的女儿玛蒂尔达 10 岁了。玛蒂尔达想看《早餐俱乐部》。当然，10 岁看《早餐俱乐部》有点小，但她的大多数朋友都看过。
So it was kind of weird that she was the only one that hadn't seen this movie. And she said that it was a conversation at slumber parties where that's a movie that some kids want to watch and that she had always said, please, I don't want to watch it. Can we watch something else? Because she wanted to watch it with me-- which I thought was really nice.
所以她是唯一没看过这部电影的人，这有点奇怪。她说在睡衣派对上，那是些孩子想看的电影，而她总是说，拜托，我不想看。我们可以看点别的吗？因为她想和我一起看——我觉得这真的很棒。
I wonder if it's like, she wants to watch it with you-- like, that's a nice thing to say to your mom. But the truth could also be, she just doesn't want to watch it with them, do you know what I mean?
我在想这是否像是，她想和你一起看——这作为一个对妈妈说的话很棒。但真相也可能是，她只是不想和她们一起看，你明白我意思吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Can you imagine watching your mom with a group of your friends, and you have no idea what's about to happen?
你能想象和一群朋友一起看你妈妈的电影，而你完全不知道接下来会发生什么吗？
Yeah. I didn't even really think about that, but yeah, I'm sure that had something to do with it. Mathilda does not like surprises.
是啊。我甚至没想过那个，但是的，我肯定那和这有关系。玛蒂尔达不喜欢惊喜。
And the fact is, Molly Ringwald preferred to watch it with Mathilda. It just seemed like it might be a nice experience to share together. And there were things in the film that she knew that she was going to want to talk to Mathilda about-- like, for instance, there's a scene where she smokes pot in the film as a teenager.
事实是，莫莉·林沃德更喜欢和玛蒂尔达一起看。这看起来是一个可以一起分享的美好体验。而且电影里有些事情她知道她会想和玛蒂尔达聊聊——比如，电影里有一个她作为青少年吸大麻的场景。
So Molly showed her The Breakfast Club , not sure at all how she was going to react, not sure what it would be like to see the film through Mathilda's eyes. We sent her a tape recorder to record what happened.
所以莫莉给她看了《早餐俱乐部》，完全不确定她会作何反应，也不确定透过玛蒂尔达的眼睛看这部电影会是什么感觉。我们寄给她一个录音机来记录发生的事。
Hello!
你好！
Which, by the way, Mathilda loved the tape recorder.
顺便说一下，玛蒂尔达很喜欢那个录音机。
Hello! So--
你好！那么——
She loved talking into the tape recorder. She loved answering questions, though she is not going to hear this radio story for a long time. That's the plan.
她喜欢对着录音机说话。她喜欢回答问题，尽管她很久以后才会听到这个电台故事。那是计划。
The Breakfast Club , if you've never seen it, is five kids. They're stuck together in school on a Saturday for all-day detention. They're kids who never would normally talk to each other in school. It's a jock, a brain, a tough kid, a popular girl, and an outsider girl. And you know, it's a John Hughes movie. They bond talking about all these things that everybody feels in high school. And you can totally see why it still gets to kids and why it's the John Hughes film that Molly Ringwald looks back on as her favorite.
《早餐俱乐部》，如果你没看过，是五个孩子。他们因为整天的留校察看而被困在学校里。他们是那种通常在学校里绝对不会说话的孩子。一个运动员，一个书呆子，一个不良少年，一个受欢迎的女孩，和一个局外女孩。你知道的，这是一部约翰·休斯电影。他们通过谈论每个人在高中时感到的所有事情而建立联系。你可以完全明白为什么它仍然能打动孩子们，以及为什么它是莫莉·林沃德回首时最喜欢的约翰·休斯电影。
So she and Mathilda, they make popcorn, they futz around with the TV, and you know, stars are just like us. They do not know how to operate their video systems either. They cannot figure out how to turn it on. And is it DVD or HDMI?
所以她和玛蒂尔达爆了爆米花，折腾电视，你知道的，明星和我们一样。她们也不知道怎么操作视频系统。她们搞不懂怎么打开它。是 DVD 还是 HDMI？
HDM-1?
HDM-1？
HDMI.
HDMI。
I mean, it sounds really silly. I mean, it was almost like a date, you know, where you just want everything to go OK, you know? I didn't want her to not like it. I didn't want her to get bored.
我是说，听起来真的很傻。我是说，这几乎像是一次约会，你知道，你只想一切都顺利进行？我不希望她不喜欢它。我不希望她觉得无聊。
OK, wait.
OK，等等。
OK, OK. It's fun to do it too.
好的，好的。这样做也很有趣。
[GASP]
[吸气]
Oh, you! Oh my god, it's you!
哦，是你！天哪，是你！
Was there any point during the film where you had second thoughts about watching it with her?
电影中有没有某个时刻让你后悔和她一起看？
The sex stuff I was a little-- I was cringing a little bit.
性爱方面的东西我有点——我有点畏缩。
Oh, are you medically frigid, or is it psychological?
哦，你是生理性冷淡还是心理性冷淡？
I didn't mean it that way. You guys are putting words into my mouth.
我不是那个意思。你们是在强词夺理。
You know, there's a whole part where everyone's saying, did you do it? Did you do it?
你知道，有一整段大家都说，你们做了吗？你们做了吗？
Why don't you just answer the question?
为什么你不直接回答这个问题？
Be honest.
诚实点。
It's no big deal.
那没什么大不了的。
Yeah, answer it.
是啊，回答它。
Just answer the question, Claire.
回答那个问题，克莱尔。
Talk to us.
跟我们谈谈。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[重叠的声音]
So then I'm thinking, she's going to ask me, what are they talking about? But then she just didn't ask. She was not-- all of that stuff she just didn't want to know.
所以我当时想，她会问我，他们在说什么？但她就是没问。她不是——所有那些事她就是不想知道。
And so I was trying to sort of ask her what she got out of that, what she thought we were talking about, but trying to ask her in such a way where I wouldn't tell her, where I wouldn't end up talking about sex if she didn't know.
所以我试图问她从中学到了什么，她觉得我们在谈论什么，但试图以一种我不会告诉她的方式去问，以一种我不会最后谈论性如果她不知道的话。
So all the talk about did she do it, did she not do it, all of that stuff, kind of--
所以所有关于她做了没有，没做没有的谈论，所有那些事，有点——
What? The what part?
什么？哪个部分？
When they were like, did you do it, did you do it, Claire, just answer the question. Answer the question.
当他们说，你做了吗，你做了吗，克莱尔，只要回答那个问题。回答那个问题。
Oh, yeah. I got that. Wait. Which part? They were-- what?
哦，是啊。我明白了。等等。哪个部分？他们当时在——什么？
And my husband's sitting there looking at me-- just, stop. Stop. She doesn't get it.
我丈夫坐在那里看着我——住嘴。住嘴。她不懂。
So this is the first time that you saw the film as a parent. Did you see it differently?
所以这是你作为父母第一次看这部电影。你看到的有什么不同吗？
Absolutely. I really did. I really kind of felt for the parents.
绝对有。我真的觉得很同情那些父母。
For people who haven't seen The Breakfast Club , a lot of it is about the kids being disappointed in the parents.
对于那些没看过《早餐俱乐部》的人，电影很大一部分是关于孩子们对父母感到失望。
Yeah. And how alone and isolated and frustrated you feel with your parents. And now I see the movie and I just think, oh, their poor parents. And I think that when it was pointed out to me that the movie just talks about how all parents suck, you know, then I thought in my mind, well, actually that might be kind of good because then she can see that she doesn't have parents like that. And then she can, you know, appreciate us.
是啊。以及你觉得与父母在一起有多孤独、孤立和沮丧。现在我看这部电影，我只会想，哦，可怜的父母们。而且当有人指出这部电影只是在谈论父母有多烂时，我心里想，嗯，其实那可能挺好，因为这样她能看到她没有那样的父母。然后她可以，你知道，感激我们。
You know, but that can go another way.
你知道，但这可能会走向另一个方向。
Yeah. That was my focus, I guess.
是啊。那是我的焦点，我想。
OK, so afterwards you're talking to her about the film. And there's this moment that gets surprisingly emotional. And let me play you that.
OK，所以后来你和她谈论这部电影。有个时刻变得非常情绪化。让我放给你听。
Which character-- when the characters talk and you think, oh, that's what I feel like, are there any that you say, yeah, that's like what I feel like?
哪个角色——当角色们谈话时，你觉得，哦，那是我感觉的样子，有没有哪个角色你说，对，那像我感觉的样子？
I guess a little bit of, like-- is he, like, Brian or something?
我想有一点点，比如——他是布莱恩吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
Brian, I should say, is the straight A student whose parents pressure him to get good grades, played by Anthony Michael Hall.
我应该说，布莱恩是那个父母逼着他拿全 A 的优等生，由安东尼·迈克尔·霍尔扮演。
You kind of feel like Brian?
你感觉有点像布莱恩？
I do kind of.
确实有点。
He's really sweet, isn't he?
他真的很贴心，不是吗？
I know, but you kind of, like, sometimes pressure me in school.
我知道，但有时你在学校会给我压力。
Wait, you think I pressure you?
等等，你觉得我给你压力？
No, but barely. Like--
不，但很少。比如——
Wow, really?
哇，真的吗？
No! Not any more! No! I take that back.
不！不再有了！不！我收回那句话。
Wait, wait, wait. Wait, no, no, no, no. No, tell me. Tell me. Oh, hey!
等等，等等，等等。等等，不，不，不，不。不，告诉我。告诉我。哦，嘿！
[SOBBING].
[抽泣]。
Hey! No, it's OK.
嘿！不，没关系。
No, it isn't!
不，不是！
No, no, no. Sweetie-- it's OK!
不，不，不。甜心——没关系的！
OK.
好的。
It's OK.
没关系的。
OK.
好的。
I'm just-- I'm just surprised.
我只是——我只是很惊讶。
But I told you barely!
但我跟你说只是很少！
Just barely, like a little bit.
只是很少，像一点点。
Yeah.
是啊。
OK. Well, you know what? That's really good for me to know. I had no idea. Like, when did I make you feel like that?
OK。好吧，你知道吗？这对我很重要。我完全不知道。你是什么时候觉得我让你有那种感觉的？
Well, you kept on saying, like, I wish I did better in school.
嗯，你一直说，比如，我希望我学校里表现得更好。
Oh, because I said that I wish I did better in school?
哦，因为我说了我希望我学校里表现得更好？
Yeah, and like you wanted me to do good.
是啊，而且你想要我表现得好。
Oh. I'm sorry I made you feel that way.
哦。很抱歉让你有那种感觉。
But you don't anymore.
但你现在不再那样了。
Do you remember the thing she's talking about of you saying to her, like, oh, I wish that I had done better in school?
你还记得她说的那件事吗？关于你说，哦，我希望我在学校里表现得更好？
I was really surprised. I was not expecting that at all. And the only thing that I can think of, really, is we have this homework battle. And it's incredibly frustrating.
我真的很惊讶。我完全没预料到会那样。我能想到的唯一一件事，真的，是我们有这个家庭作业大战。而且它令人难以置信地沮丧。
It's frustrating to get her to do the work?
让她做作业很令人沮丧吗？
Yeah, because it's really easy. And I'm not just saying that as an adult. I mean, it's easy.
是的，因为这很简单。我不是作为一个成年人这样说的。我是说，这很容易。
It's easy work for her.
对她来说很容易。
It's easy work for her. If she would just sit down, do it, it would take 15 minutes, 20 minutes. But she resents the fact that she has to do it so much. And it became such a battle that she would sort of lie sprawled out, kind of barely write-- you couldn't even read her writing. And I would just get so frustrated with her.
对她来说很简单。如果她能坐下来做完，只需要 15 到 20 分钟。但她非常反感她必须做这件事。这变成了一场拉锯战，她会躺在那里，几乎连写字都不行——你甚至看不懂她的字。我会因为她而变得非常沮丧。
And I would yell at her and say, you can do better than this. You're smarter than this-- you know, all the things that parents say. And I think it must have affected her. And then she said, well, you don't do it anymore. And the reason why I don't do it anymore is because I don't do her homework with her anymore because I can't. I find it too frustrating.
我会对她吼说，你可以表现得比这更好。你比这更聪明——你知道，父母常说的话。我觉得这肯定影响了她。然后她说，你不再那样了。我不再那样的原因是，因为我不再和她一起做作业了，因为我做不到。我觉得这太令人沮丧了。
Oh, when she said that, I thought, oh, she's just being protective of you, you know?
哦，当她说那句话时，我想，哦，她只是在保护你，你知道吗？
I think she was being protective of me too. I think the thing that I noticed the most was Mathilda kind of wanting to make me feel OK. She really did not want to hurt my feelings or make me upset, and she wants to please me too. I can hear that when I-- yeah.
我觉得她也在保护我。我注意到最多的一点是，玛蒂尔达想要让我感觉良好。她真的不想伤害我的感情或让我难过，而且她也想让我开心。当我——是的，我能听到。
Well, the fact that the next thing that happens, she instantly goes to I have better parents than they do.
好吧，事实是接下来的事是她立刻说我比他们有更好的父母。
Yeah, I know, like it's scripted. I know.
是啊，我知道，就像照着剧本念的一样。我知道。
So is there anything else that you got out of the movie that you--
那么你从电影里学到的还有别的什么你——
Um, well, I have better parents than them.
嗯，好吧，我比他们有更好的父母。
You're just saying that to make me feel better. Come on!
你只是为了让我感觉好点才那么说。拜托！
I mean, it was bizarre how she just said the thing that I hoped she would get out of it. She knows. I mean, she can intuit that. She knew that I was hoping for that. Yeah, she was giving me a little present wrapped in a bow.
我是说，她就像我希望她从中学到的一样说出那句话，这太离奇了。她知道。我是说，她能直觉到。她知道我希望那样。是的，她给了我一份包着蝴蝶结的小礼物。
But at a moment where it doesn't feel like that at all.
但在一个一点都不觉得像那样的时刻。
No. No, not at all.
不。不，一点也不。
The whole thing left her wondering a lot about what happened when Mathilda cried and how she handled it, and should she have let Mathilda talk for longer, and should  she have asked her more questions or different questions?
整件事让她思考了很多关于玛蒂尔达哭的时候发生了什么，她是怎么处理的，她是不是应该让玛蒂尔达多说一会儿，她是不是应该问她更多问题或者问不同的问题？
You know, you just can never know what things that you say to your kids are going to stay with them, just little things said in a passing moment that are going to bounce around in their heads and lead them to conclusions that you don't intend or expect in any way.
你知道，你永远无法知道你对孩子说的哪些话会留在他们心里，只是在不经意间说出的小事，却会在他们的脑海里不断回响，引导他们得出你完全没意图或预料到的结论。
Yeah. I think there's always moments where you perceive things differently. I know it with my own mom and dad. I mean, there are times where I'll tell a story that I've heard a million times over the years. And my mom will just completely switch it up. Or she'll see it completely differently.
是啊。我觉得总会有时刻你感知事情的方式不同。我从我父母那里就知道这一点。我是说，有些时候我会讲一个我多年来听过无数遍的故事。我妈妈会完全把它变个样。或者她会完全以不同的方式看待它。
Like, some story from your childhood? Like, you're telling the story about something they did?
比如，童年的某个故事？比如，你在讲关于他们做过的事的故事？
Yeah.
是啊。
And they're just like, no, no, no.
他们只会说，不，不，不。
Well, yeah. I mean, there's one-- I come from a family where my sister was sort of designated as the great beauty in the family. And this was just known. I was the talented one. My brother was the smart one, and my sister was the beautiful one.
嗯，是的。我是说，有一个——我来自一个家庭，我妹妹被指定为家庭中的大美人。这是众所周知的。我是那个有才华的。我哥哥是聪明的，我妹妹是漂亮的。
And I remember actually asking my mom at-- I must have been around Mathilda's age-- if she thought that I was pretty. And she said, you're cute. And--
我还记得我问我妈——我当时一定和玛蒂尔达差不多大——她觉得我漂不漂亮。她说，你很可爱。然后——
Ooh.
哦。
Yeah. And that is really not what you want to hear when you're 10 years-- I mean, now it's OK. I would be OK with cute. But when you're 10, it was just devastating.
是啊。那在你 10 岁时真的不是你想听到的——我是说，现在没关系。我可以接受“可爱”。但当你 10 岁时，那简直是毁灭性的。
And she completely denies that now. And I mean, something that would have such an impact on me-- I mean, I wasn't making it up. It really affected me.
而她现在完全否认了。我的意思是，那种对我影响这么大的事情——我不是编造出来的。它真的影响了我。
And she just says it didn't happen.
而她只是说没发生过。
She says, I always knew that you were beautiful. Ask your father.
她说，我一直都知道你很漂亮。去问你爸爸。
And obviously if she had any idea how it would bounce around in your head, she would have never said it too. She didn't think, like, oh, that's going to stick.
显然，如果她知道这会如何在你脑海里回响，她也绝不会说出来的。她没想，哦，那会留下阴影。
No. I don't think that she did.
不。我觉得她没那么想。
I have a friend. Her mom would tell her and her sister, no, you girls are average.
我有个朋友。她妈会告诉她和她姐姐，不，你们这些女孩很普通。
Oh!
哦！
No, like, you girls are average. Average, you know-- like, you're smart, but you're average smart. And I was like, wow, you were not raised by Jews, man. That is not the message you get. I mean, in my experience, there's a lot of, like, you're so special. You're the most special. You're so special-- you know, the boys and the girls. You know, she's the most talented.
不，就像，你们这些女孩很普通。普通，你知道——就像，你们很聪明，但你们是普通聪明。我说，哇，你不是犹太人养大的吧，哥们。那不是你得到的信息。我是说，以我的经验，有很多像，你太特别了。你是最特别的。你太特别了——你知道，男孩女孩都一样。你知道，她是最有才华的。
Well, I was always told that I was special. I mean, there was no question that I was special and that I was destined for greatness.
嗯，我一直被告知我很特别。我是说，毫无疑问我很特别，我注定要成就伟大。
As a  little kid?
当小孩的时候？
As a little kid.
当小孩的时候。
Wow.
哇。
From the time that I was really little. I mean, to the point where-- this is kind of heavy, but I'll tell you. Anyway, my first brother died. He was the first, and I was the last, so we never met. But my mom was understandably just devastated by this and was sort of suicidal for a while-- I mean, didn't actually try anything, but she was considering.
从我真正小的时候开始。我是说，甚至到了——这有点沉重，但我告诉你。总之，我的第一个哥哥去世了。他是第一个，我是最后一个，所以我们从没见过面。但我妈妈因为这个理所当然地崩溃了，有一段时间甚至有点自杀倾向——我是说，没真的尝试什么，但她考虑过。
And then was-- this makes her sound so hippy-dippy, and she's not at all. But she believes that she conversed with a spirit. And what they said basically-- and this is a story that I've heard since I was very small-- that she was here for another reason, for someone else. And as soon as I was born, she knew that it was me.
然后是——这让她听起来像嬉皮士，而她一点也不。但她相信她与灵魂交流过。他们基本上说的是——这是一个我从很小就听过的故事——她来到这里是有另一个原因，是为了别人。我一出生，她就知道是我。
That's a lot to put on you.
这对你来说负担太重了。
Yeah, it's heavy. It's really--
是啊，很沉重。真的——
Like, she told you that when you were a little girl? Like, that she was put on this Earth because of you?
比如，她当你是个小女孩时就告诉你了？比如，她来到这个地球是因为你？
Yeah. She believed that that was why-- yeah. Because she knew that there was some reason why she was supposed to stick around and--
是啊。她相信那就是为什么——是啊。因为她知道她必须留下是有某种原因的——
And stay alive. And it was to have this little girl who was you, who was such a special gift to the world.
并且活下去。那就是为了拥有这个小女孩，也就是你，你是给世界的一份多么特别的礼物。
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
So how strange that you would end up famous by the age of 15 or something?
那你最终在 15 岁左右变得出名不是很奇怪吗？
Well, I kind of had to. I mean, I kept my mom alive.
嗯，我不得不。我是说，我让我妈活了下来。
And so then when you actually did become a movie star as a teenager, did she take that as proof, like, oh, see, that was all true?
那么当你确实作为青少年成了电影明星，她把它当作证据吗，比如，哦看，那都是真的？
Yeah.
是啊。
And did you at the time? Did the whole story fit together for you too?
那你当时呢？整个故事对你来说也吻合吗？
Yeah. I had to succeed. I had to be great.
是啊。我必须成功。我必须伟大。
What a lot of pressure on you.
你身上压力太大了。
I know. And then what do I do? I turn around, and I pressure my daughter, because I think she's so great. I know.
我知道。然后我做了什么？我转过头来，给我女儿施压，因为我觉得她太棒了。我知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
Ira J. Glass with Molly Ringwald. She's still in the movies. She's shooting one right now. And she's the author of a novel made of short stories called When it Happens to You .
艾拉·J·格拉斯采访莫莉·林沃德。她还在拍电影。她最近正在拍一部。她是短篇小说集《当它发生在你身上》的作者。
[MUSIC - "HOW DO YOU SEE ME" BY MATRIMONY]
[音乐 - “你怎么看我” 作者：婚姻]
Our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Chana Joffe-Walt, Sarah Koenig, Miki Meek, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Ira Glass. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from Alison Davis. Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon is our production manager. Elise Bergerson is our administrative assistant. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Research help from Michelle Harris. Music help from Damien Graef and Rob Geddis.
今天的节目由乔纳森·门吉瓦制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、肖恩·科尔、斯蒂芬妮·傅、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、莎拉·科尼格、米基·米克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和艾拉·格拉斯参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。艾莉森·戴维斯提供制作帮助。塞思·林德是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿是我们的制作经理。埃莉斯·伯格森是我们的行政助理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥韦茨负责我们的网站。米歇尔·哈里斯提供研究帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·盖迪斯提供音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Our website, thisamericanlife.org. Thanks, as always, to our programs cofounder Torey Malatia and to our boss, Mr. Ira Glass. While he was hosting the show this week, he spent a little time moonlighting as a Realtor. He's really got to work on his pitch.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。我们的网站是 thisamericanlife.org。一如既往，感谢我们的项目联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚和我们的老板，艾拉·格拉斯先生。当他这周主持节目时，他花了一点时间兼职做房地产中介。他真的得好好练练他的推销话术。
Look at that really [BLEEP] small house over there.
看那边那栋非常[哔]小的房子。
I'm Nancy Updike. Ira J. Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是南希·厄普代克。艾拉·J·格拉斯下周会回来，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC - "WHO ARE YOU WHO AM I" BY SPIDA]
[音乐 - “你是谁，我是谁” 作者：斯皮达]
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。